comment ça va aujourd'hui bien regarder
qu'on est au soleil il fait encore beau
il fait chaud que ce gars là pour vous
présenter aujourd'hui une nouvelle
caméra c'est lé in-stat 360 x 3 à la
fois caméra d'action à la fois caméra à
360 degrés en train de filmer tout de
suite avec d'ailleurs aujourd'hui c'est
une vidéo qui réalisé en partenariat
avec in-stat un stade 360 qui me dit
qu'un membre monsieur roux est ce que tu
voudrais pas tester notre nouvelle
caméra 360 nouvelle caméra d'action et
je dois vous avouer que là franchement
ou simple s amuse déjà depuis quelques
temps avec caméra très cool vous allez
voir on peut faire plein de choses faire
tellement de mode que je peux pas vous
le résumé en quelques secondes comme ça
donc regardez bien cette vidéo jusqu'au
bout pour tout savoir et puis bien
évidemment pour tout savoir de la
tutelle si vous n'êtes pas abonné je
vous invite à venir vous abonner
actionner la petite loge pour quantifier
dès qu une prochaine vidéo arrivera donc
aujourd'hui on se teste cette nouvelle
caméra on peut marcher avec on peut se
balader on a de la stabilisation tous
les côtés ça ne bouge pas assez solide
c'est sérieux c'est signé un stade 360
et surtout c'est la x3 et l'ex trois ans
elle envoie du bois
[Musique]
j'ai filmé quasiment toute la vidéo avec
la caméra à 360 me convient que je vous
la montre donc je vais vous la montre et
regardez ici passer cette nouvelle
caméra un stade 360
x360 et et qui est vachement cool c'est
que vous avez un écran qui est beaucoup
plus grand que ce qu'on avait sur la
génération précédente
là on est sur un écran de 2,29 pouces en
verre trempé donc ça en termes de
résistance c'est pareil puisque c'est
une caméra d'action ça va le faire on a
toujours la double lentille et d'un côté
l'hôte comme celle du 360 c'est normal
vous allez retrouver de combien la
recharge est ici en usb c est vous avez
juste là alors il faut que je les
teignes pour vous le montrer et bien
vous allez avoir ici sur le côté une
batterie dont vous pouvez venir changer
votre batterie si vous avez besoin est
ici le lecteur de cartes microsd qui
situent juste donc voilà donc vous venez
mettre une petite carte là c'est
pratique c'est vite fait c'est bien la
batterie elle est un peu plus grosses on
arrive sur 2800 milliampères heures à
cette année on veut avoir un capteur 1/2
pouces qui est amélioré par rapport à la
génération précédente et puis vous avez
plein de mode pour venir filmer ici
c'est ça qui est vachement pratique en
360° de pour faire un time lapse taf
schiste en accéléré le bullet time
l'enregistrement bouclent leur rafale
l'intervalle photo hdr la photo la vidéo
la vidéo hd est bref ça c'est vachement
bien et si vous voulez que sur une seule
lentilles vous avez de la vidéo vous
avez le mode micky aussi très cool et je
vous en parle également quelques
instants l'enregistrement boucla photos
bref voilà donc vous avez plein de modes
différents et vous allez voir il joue le
monde entier qu un sport que dans
l'application et bien vous avez plein de
tutos qui vont vous montrer l'étendue
des possibilités que vous avez avec
cette caméra d'action caméra l'action
également à 360° le formage même bien
parce que je trouve très compact très
petit l'idée c'est que cette caméra pour
la glisser facilement dans un sac à dos
dans une poche vous la prenez vous allez
vous balader très très facilement avec
vous avez quatre boutons pour l'allumer
un bouton recueillir personnalisé vous
lancer si vous jetez des rafales bref
c'est extrêmement pratique des micros
qui sont tout autour et une fois de plus
vous en pendant quelques instants puis
vous venez le vice est ici tu avais un
petit pas de vis à leurs petits
pâtissiers découlent pour différents
accessoires notamment une petite paire
chasse elfique vous allez pouvoir venir
et bien hop la mettre là et qui va
devenir invisible grâce aux différents
modes si vous voulez aller beaucoup plus
loin bien vous avez une énorme perche
celle là qui va jusqu'à trois mètres
alors bon on va pas aller jusqu'à 3
mètres ici mais on peut aller hyper loin
et des manières mener la vie c'est juste
là pour ça c'est vachement pratique et
vous allez voir dans quelques instants
l'étendue des possibilités qu'on a avec
sans oublier ce petit truc là en fait
c'est a fait un peu différemment avancée
pour le faire le mode bullet time pour
faire tourner la caméra autour de vous
avant il y avait une espèce de truc
coude et à 90° où on le faisait tourner
comme ça aujourd'hui on prend la ficelle
on prend aux tierces à tourner et on a
du bullet time donc à plein de petits
accessoires très cool vous avez
également celui là pourrait venir
prendre et mettre derrière pour pouvoir
venir vous connecter up la regarder en
lightning directement sur un iphone donc
ça c'est cool et puis on sait que un
stade 360 et bien offrent des connexions
vraiment très pratique avec notamment
leurs potes et puis vous avez également
cet accessoire là qui est très cool pour
venir protéger vos optique et pas les
alliés parce que si vous voulez du rendu
de qualité venir les protège donc vous
les mettez dedans alors à qui s'adresse
cette caméra d'action cette nouvelle un
stade 360 x 3 et bien à tous ceux et
toutes celles qui veulent créer du
contenu créer du contenu pour les
réseaux que ce soit un tick tock que ce
soit sur youtube même où vous voulez
comme vous pouvez venir cadrés et
choisir un format 16 9 9 16e même un
petit carré vous faites ce que vous
voulez préfère en post production c'est
ça qui fâchent mans intéressant avec ce
typologie de produits c'est que vous
venez vous filmez vous posez pas de
question et après un poste produite à 21
ans je peux admettre comme ça tient
jean-paul décliné pour tik tok tâche
peut le décliner également pour youtube
tiens je veux mettre sur facebook
peut-être pouvait le faire on s'adresse
donc aux créateurs de contenu aux
vidéastes également photographe mais
également à tout plein de sportifs des
athlètes si c'est en bmx si vous sautez
en parapente en parachute fait du
belgium bref avec ça vous avez moult
possibilités c'est ça qui est vachement
bien et en plus de ça c'est une caméra
qui est très solide résistante et qui
étanche jusqu'à 10 mètres alors après si
vous voulez aller un peu plus bas il
existe un accessoire qui va venir
l'englobé vous le mettez dans une espèce
de petite boîte une petite coque et vous
descendez beaucoup plus bas si vous le
souhaitez mais déjà telle qu'elle est là
jusqu'à 10 mètres et ça c'est chouette
là on est sur le mode mon objectif c'est
à dire qu'on a un seul objectif qui l'a
filmé c'est celui devant celui de
derrière de film absolument pas l'idée
c'est vous pouvez choisir soit entre du
16/9 comme seka tout de suite ou alors
entre dunes 9/16 se tourner comme ça si
vous voulez faire plus tôt pour
instagram pour différents réseaux &
company 4k 30 images par secondes ça
sera largement suffisant pour tous les
créatifs toutes les personnes qui
veulent aller sur les réseaux qui volent
du contenu de bonne qualité tout en
gardant une vague stabilisation et ça
c'est plutôt bien bon bon mental s'amuse
à la faire sauter comme ça donc là on
est sur un champ de vision qui est large
mais on peut encore revenir l'augmenter
encore venir l'agrandir là c'est sur le
mode ultra je vais être un peu plus
large on va venir ouvrir encore en dire
plus un petit peu les murs toujours en
4k 30 images par seconde comme ça ne
vient pas du tout dégradé la qualité
mais on peut encore venir tous un peu
plus encore venir ouvrir davantage
anasur 2,7 qu'à 30 images par seconde je
peux monter dans 50 ou en 60 images par
secondes ça vient légèrement dégradé un
peu la qualité la résolution sera un peu
moins élevé mais si vous voulez ouvrir
au maximum tenant à bout de bras comme
ça doit vous pouvez alors y un côté très
pratique et c'est le canard et voiliers
après s'il vient filmer tous carreaux je
peux pour autant la jeune fille tout de
suite que sur le mono objectif donc j'ai
pas m'amuser à venir monter la perche
extrêmement ou que je peux faire lorsque
je vais l'utiliser en mode 362 comme on
est sur une caméra 360 degrés on veut
pouvoir capter du son à 360 degrés donc
vous allez avoir des micros situées tout
autour de votre caméra en tout vous avez
quatre micro alors l'agent registre j'ai
pris un petit micro externe histoire de
maximiser d'avoir une petite boulette
anti vent mais déjà comme vous l'avez là
c'est pas mal permet de capter l'audio
exactement là où est la source notez que
vous avez un petit micro juste là vous
avez exactement la même chose de l'autre
côté qui me croquer situe juste en bas
juste ici en haut et en bas micro qui se
situeront sur les côtés là est également
sur l'autre côté ici autant dire que
l'audio on l'a tous les côtés d'ailleurs
tout de suite vous êtes en train
d'écouter l'audio directement de la
caméra donc si j'aime balade autour de
la caméra envoyée chez le tour je fais
le tourner la caméra je fais tourner la
source j'essaye de ne pas trop bouger la
caméra je fais tour je me balade autour
comme ça vous pourrez capter l'audio qui
vient de tous les côtés et ça aussi
c'est plutôt bien
mais j'étais avec l'intérêt ici c'est de
voir venir filmer avec votre caméra à
360 degrés comme vous souhaitez donc
lâchant 5,7 cas je suis à 30 images par
seconde donc je peux venir balader soit
être sur moi qu'un point sur moi soit
faire le point exactement de l'autre
côté si je souhaite me balader à droite
me balader à gauche donc ça permet
vraiment de pousser la créativité comme
vous voulez à son maximum si vous voulez
venir vous amuser vous balader et bien
ça c'est vachement cool parce que vous
êtes libre vous êtes libre vous prenez
plus est lorsque vous venez film et vous
avez juste à appuyer sur rec vous hri
cordée et après vous choisissez
directement en post prod la voulait
faire le point de focus est justement la
post prod je vous montrais il ya un
software qui est vachement bien fait que
ce soit sur différents types de bécanes
je vous dire ça peut-être que ça soit
vous allez voir c'est vachement bien et
un autre qui est très pratique c'est la
photo passe comme si une caméra comme
vous avait démenti d'un côté de l'autre
et bien on peut faire de la vidéo et
c'est chouette on va tout de suite on
peut également faire de la photo qu'on
pouvait faire la photo à 360° vous posez
dessus vous appuyer mais ça va venir
c'était au tour donc après pourrait
venir une fois de plus pareil en post
prod modules et recadrer faire ce que
vous voulez je pense assez malin parce
qu'en fait en une seule photo vous
captez tout ce qui se passe autour de
vous donc le panorama est très vite fait
là où avec un smartphone vous allez vous
embêter panorama panorama panorama là
vous mettez le sucre claque un clic et
vous avez panorama assez bien 60 12
mégapixels ici rien que ça les regarder
lorsque vous avez fait votre photo à
360° pas pouvez venir vous balader
dedans directement donc vous avez votre
image on peut venir nous met dans
l'image on peut venir vraiment vivre ses
souvenirs directement et c'est beaucoup
plus immersif dont je trouve un truc
assez marrant et une fois que vous avez
fait ça et bien vous choisissez par
exemple je me débats comme ça c'est pas
mal tient au pl oui j'ai choisi mon
format 16/9 9/16 une fois de plus je
choisis un petit peu je fais un peu
comme je veux et je vais me mettre ici
en 9/16 je vais juste me faire
disparaître un petit peu hop là la
perche j'exporte je clique ici je fais
exporter une photo recadrée plutôt
exporté photos à 360° donc j'exporte ma
photo recadrée elle va partir
directement voilà elle a enregistré dans
l'album du téléphone je vais ensuite ici
et et voyez je retrouve ma photo
directement donc lorsque je shoote j'ai
pas vraiment embêté je prends j'appuie
et ensuite je viens choisir ce que je
veux et j'ai ma photo directement là où
ça vachement pratique
il ya un autre mode qui est marrant
s'appelle le mot demi et le mode ni ckoi
et bien je viens film et se pose ma
perche comme ça en fait elle va être en
perpendiculaire à moi et là je suis en
train de filmer comme si et bien je
n'avais pas de faire venir également la
vente directe match comme ça donc le
truc est assez marrant mater chemins
invisibles on voit que moi par contre
ici l'inconvénient c'est de lui
uniquement en 1080p à 60 images par
seconde pas plus pas moins voyez ça se
tient comme ça ça moi elle est couchée
comme ça c'est très pratique alors c'est
très bizarre parce qu'il fait un peu de
place devant peu bizarre pour marcher
dans la rue mais vous avez ces petits
mots deux mois et demi qui est très
rigolo comme ça moi ce que j'aime bien
ce que je trouve extrêmement pratique
ici c'est que que vous ayez un mode mis
comme je vous montre tout à l'heure vous
soyez comme ça en 360° bien votre
marshall est totalement invisible si
bien que vous vous baladez comme ça
pouvait venir module maîtres d'un côté
de l'autre et vous avez plus de perche
qu'on trouve que truc est juste géniale
et vous allez regarder voyez en à
l'ombre c'est la perche qui est là et
pour autant la perche elle est invisible
satan mais pour toutes les personnes qui
sont créatives et qui veulent nous faire
disparaître cette terre est bien des
pena alors c'est pas tout nouveau
attention à la perche aux visites en
plus qui existait déjà mais j'aime bien
sa pratique j'ai autant vous le montrer
alors je vous montre ça c'est bien
surtout c'est par chance elle fuit on
peut la montée on peut la montée on peut
l'éloigner on peut l'éloigner on peut
l'éloigner on peut la montée jusqu'à 3
mètres qui fait que là on a l'impression
que je filme avec un drone alors que
c'est une perche à celle fille après
l'inconvénient c'est que est bien mais
micro faut quand même loin de là j'ai un
petit micro externe donc ça permet que
vous puissiez entendre mais voyez j'ai
ce mode un peu drones que je trouve
vraiment génial comme ça on va visiter
des choses qu'on ne verrait pas et
lorsque je fais des plans en skate par
exemple où je suis en train de rouler et
que on a passé au cochon android
supporte juste avec ma perche comme ça
donc pas besoin de demander
d'autorisation pour venir filmer en
ville c'est penhars et smooth et fluide
c'est cool ça c'est bien et après avoir
des plages peut la réduire
tranquillement je la ramène vers moi et
je peux continuer à venir à vous parler
léger dans les jeux tout simplement donc
ça aussi c'est chouette puisque je vous
parlais d'action comme tout à l'heure
c'est une caméra qui est totalement
stabilisée on a un truc qui s'appelle le
maintien de l'horizon alors le matin à
l'horizon c'est quoi je prends ma came
japy vote ça bouge pas voyez ça c'est
quand même vachement cool parce que
quand vous vous baladez vous bouger tout
est en train de sauter de courir pas ça
ne bouge pas quand on peut se faire un
footing si vous voulez je suis pas un
grand sportif mais si on décide par
exemple de se prendre le banc en face et
d'y aller hop hop hop et de sauter et
bien c'est stabiliser ses coûts voilà
j'ai fait l'effort pour la journée il
faut avoir le bon axe comme ça vraiment
pour ça bouge pas si vous allez bon axe
vous êtes juste auto apposant un truc
qui bouge pas et pourtant la caméra
tourne donc pour plein de choses caméra
d'action du vélo tout ce que vous voulez
ça c'est vachement bien comment les
seconds caméra qui s'adresse aux
créatifs enfin les options on peut tous
les côtés une option qui est vachement
intéressante c'est le time lapse en huit
cas où il n'y a pas de petite taille 908
à haute résolution assez chouette
[Musique]
on a également un mode bullet time un
peu comme dans matrix vous savez lorsque
tous les appareils photos qui le choc
lorsqu'il tombe en arrière comme ça vous
pouvez le faire en 4k 120 images par
seconde et même en trois cas vous
descendez un petit peu la résolution par
contre vous montez en 180 images par
seconde le résultat reste quand même
très bluffant une fois que vous avez
récupéré tous vos fichiers vous les
mettez soit dans votre téléphone soit
dans votre ordinateur je vais vous
montrer notamment à ses deux ordinateurs
comment on fait et bien vous avez un
petit logiciel de montage qui s'appelle
un stade 360 studio c'est le 2022
version 2020 dont vous venez vous
récupérez tous vos fichiers directement
vous venez par exemple réussi vous
ajoutez des fichiers comme ça
directement dans votre logiciel là je
vous montre par exemple j'ai ma vidéo
ici alors je suis 360° donc je peux
venir me balader hop là je peux venir
zoomer dézoomer je peux venir recadrer
faire comme je veux donc le touquet
quand même vachement pratique et ensuite
j call ans et donc par exemple je suis
là hop là je sais que je vais partir en
skate donc là je vais venir raccourcir
ici pour venir commençait là parce que
là je suis en train de rouler en skate
donc lâché dans une zone d'ombré ça ne
va pas des masses on va commencer
directement au soleil tape je prends au
paquebot soleil je mets un point
d'intérêt et je vous dis que je veux
quoi atteint ça c'est naturel je peux
mettre comme ça si je veux je peux
passer comme ça en plan un peu plus
large alors j'ai une boule de cristal on
va éviter gme tiny planète l'histoire de
ce marais mais on va éviter puis après
je conviens module est directement ici
donc là haut up lâché au train de partir
aux quatre donc lâché en train de
vouloir montrer ça je sais que là je
vais prendre un petit virage sur le côté
donc comme je mélange mais un petit
point d'intérêt j'avance légèrement hop
paf autre point d'intérêt et je vais
directement dans mon virage là qui est
un peu plus loin effectivement et je
veux mettre un peu plus large la up et
je repars donc là je suis comme ça tac
tac tac ça va bien donc la voyais je me
suis mis une petite transition je viens
ici je mets la lecture donc là je me
vois et on suggère mon mouvement qui va
c'est donc voyez vous éditez très très
facilement donc ça c'est une partie je
veux continuer si hop là je mets un
petit point d'intérêt et je veux mettre
en tout cas pour le plus large et je
veux être directement sur des chaussures
je trouve ça marrant je n'en mets un
petit point d'intérêt aux plages avance
aux points d'intérêt et je vais
récupérer la vue arrière europe et là on
est partis dont vous voyez ça me fait
des petites transitions qui sont assez
marrante hop là je suis comme ça et
attention vous êtes prêt un plat on y va
et entourent onoma derrière donc comme
ça vous venez édité très très facilement
et vous venez créer des fichiers que
vous exportez ensuite vous cliquez ici
vous choisissez l'endroit vous voulez le
mettre là par exemple je veux pas être
en 1920 je m en 4 ko
3840 par 2160 donc comme ça c'est plutôt
cool donc vous choisissez après en
fonction de là vous à l'exporter comment
vous voulez exporter et vous le faites
pour tous vos fichiers et vous avez un
plugin vous pouvez me remettre
directement il vous l'avez juste en bas
ça regardez ici pour utiliser dans
premiere pro et vous pouvez également
ensuite exportée dans final cut pro 10
donc le truc est très très chouette donc
ça c'est pour la version ordinateur le
logiciel existe sur mac mais également
sur pc vous avez également une
application sur ios mais également sur
android l'application est super
intéressante pourquoi et bien parce que
déjà vous choisissez votre caméra un la
moment où je tourne cette vidéo la x3
n'est pas encore sorti donc je voir la x
2 voir toutes les autres caméras
d'instinct 360 mais le truc qui est cool
c'est qui vous met pénale monnaies vous
explique le time lapse donne des idées
sur du bullet time kung fu pics sur les
tracks vous avez plein de possibilités
en taille ni planète le choc là bas bref
vous avez plein de choses qu'on peut
venir à prendre directement aussi pour
venir créer comme vous le souhaitez donc
je trouve ça vachement bien et ensuite
vous venez connecter votre caméra de la
même manière donc je prends des caméras
je la lui même très très facilement et
une fois qu'elle a démarré juste appuyé
sur mon petit bouton au milieu ici elle
se connecte directement à la caméra
normalement je rejoins donc là je peux
venir apporter directement je peux venir
ajouté directement donc là je peux venir
tout piloté directement depuis son
smartphone et ensuite j'ai tout mon
album avec tout ce que je vais avoir
filmé ici vous voyez là par exemple je
vais rouler tu peux venir nous déplacer
ici je vois que je suis là je peux venir
des zooms et je peux venir zoom et la
voyez abla typiquement je mets une pause
je reviens sur moi et là je peux me
mettre au plat un petit point
directement en me disant que hop là je
suis là on suit je continue je reprends
hop là je mets une pause je mets un
point là et ensuite je me mets un point
de l'autre côté ici au plat ce qui fait
que ensuite lorsque je vais venir
reprendre ma lecture un peu avant et
bien je vais me retrouver avec mon
action voyez où je suis comme ça et
ensuite ça va venir pivoter d'un côté et
de l'autre qui est assez marrant alors
après je peux venir module est pas mal
de choses j'ai plein d'options au niveau
de la colorimétrie au niveau du multi
view ci et ça je peux également venir
faire un tracking c'est à dire que je
vais me suivre moi je me choisit moi et
je vais faire suivi du sujet donc si sur
certains plans et bien ça bouge un peu
tous les côtés mais je veux qu'un focus
sur moi je vais avoir un focus chambre
ont volé il ya plein de chasse très très
cool qu'on peut bien faire ensuite vous
venez exporter directement c'est un
outil qui est très facile c'est très
intuitif pour venir modifier directement
aux hits et tous vos fichiers et ensuite
pouvoir les mettre directement sur les
réseaux sociaux il ya un autre mode qui
est très pratique c'est une mode
d'enregistrement bouffe ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'en fait vous avez
votre caméra qui est posée et elle va
enregistrer tout le temps et elle va
garder en mémoire les dernières secondes
1 30 dernières secondes un bref peu
importe le chiffre est le truc qui est
vachement intéressant là dessus c'est
que par exemple brut comme boutique
d'ashkan vous venez film et vous mettez
sur votre bécane vous le mettez dans
votre bagnole vous êtes en route et là
il se passe quoi que ce soit il ya un
accident un problème vous appuyer sa
garde l'enregistrement dans le passé et
ça vient vous sauvegardez votre fichier
comme ça vous avez vos preuves en gros
l'idée c'est sa vie à écrire en
permanence sur la carte ça évite
d'enregistrer des choses pour rien ça
l'a écrit sarah écrit quand vous avez
besoin pas vous appuyer c'est pas mal
aussi puisque on se parle de créatif on
veut des fois se parler de différents
modes de colorimétrie pour venir bosser
alors moi je fais tout tout de suite
envie vide celle là on aura les couleurs
les plus pétantes et quelque chose de
plus tonique vous pouvez bien filmé sur
un mode standard qui sera un tout petit
peu moins tonique colleville et après
pourrait également venir filmer en log
c'est à dire en flat et appliquer une
colorimétrie derrière si vous le
souhaitez ça si vous voulez venir
vraiment poussé le niveau d'exigence le
plus loin possible ça peut être
intéressant pour venir à faire un match
et la colorimétrie entrant en boîtier
entre votre caméra pour vous ayez un
projet qui soit complètement cohérent
dans cette caméra questerre raconter ce
qu'elle est intéressante parce qu'elle
n'est pas intéressante en moi j'aime
bien l'idée j'aime beaucoup l'idée ce
n'est pas la première génération y en
avait eu d'autres cas d évolution à
chaque fois fatalement il ya une
batterie qui est plus grosse il ya plus
de puissance pour faire plus de choses
et des nouveaux modes qui font leur
apparition c'est toujours une très jolie
mise à jour c'est une caméra qui va être
super bien pour des créatifs qui veulent
une caméra d'action qu'on va avoir dans
la poche qu'on va glisser facilement
dans un sac on va voir tout le temps
avec soit y avait une idée je veux le
faire j'ai ma caméra je le tourne tant
il se passe quelque chose je prends la
caméra j'appuie je tourne le film elle
est très rapide les menus sont symboles
utilise facilement on la comprend
facilement bref facile à prendre en main
elle coûte 539 euros 99 c'est un tarif
sac ou que je trouve très cohérent par
rapport à ce que peut faire cette caméra
donc c'est correct ça m'a bien pour
autant ça va pas venir remplacer si vous
voulez aller sur des formats très
exigeant un boîtier qu'on pourra
utiliser pour venir filmer notamment ce
que je fais sur youtube en règle
générale ag quasiment tous filmés avec
cette caméra pour vraiment venir vous la
montrer qu'on puisse vraiment
s'imprégner alors moi l'idée et se
trouve bien ce qu'elle remplacera ma
caméra principale la réponse est non
parce que c'est une bonne caméra
d'action que je peux venir utiliser pour
plein de plan créatif la réponse est oui
à très grand oui peut être une chouette
chose que instinct 360 a vraiment mis le
paquet avec une très jolie caméra
maintenant à vous de me dire si elle est
faite pour vous si elle pourrait vous
tentez 6e vous bottez si vous pourriez
vous me racheter une caméra l'info comme
celle là est ce qu elle correspond à
votre workflow est-ce que vous en avez
le besoin qu'est ce que vous pensez de
tous ces modes quel est le mode qui
pourrait le plus vous intéressés s'étant
d'ailleurs qui vous intéressent plus
qu'un autre est ce que vous êtes plus
team 360° est ce que vous êtes plus team
4k 120 fps est ce que vous aimez les
ralentis les time lapse est ce que vous
aimez quand ça dépote de tous les côtés
dites le moi juste en bas en commentaire
moi je trouve intéressante jeu très
content de l'avant essayé merci à 1 560
d'abord sponsorisé cette vidéo et puis
on se retrouve très bientôt bien
évidemment pour continuer à parler
taille parce qu'il ya tellement de
choses que tous les côtés ses explosifs
et puis voyez caméra en utilisant à
plein d'autres fois on a tenu bon ça
c'est chouette ah les cons et sans doute
vous embrasse mais toto
[Musique]